[Applaudissements]
village au fond de la
vallée comme égaré presque
ignoré voici quand la nuit
étoilée un nouveau nez nous est
donné Jean-François Lico il se nomme il
est joufl tendre et rosé à l'église beau
petit homme demain tu seras
baptisé uneoche
sa
VO dit au monde qui
s'étonne c'est pour Jean-François
Nico c'est pour accueillir une
[Musique]
âme une fleur qui s'ouvre au
jour à peine à peine une flamme encore
faible qui réclame protection tendresse
amour
[Musique]
village au fond de la vallée loin des
chemins loin des humains voici qu'après
19 années cœur en et mooi Jean-François
prend pour femme la douélise blanche
comme fleur de pommier devant Dieu dans
la vieille église ce jour ils se sont
[Musique]
mariés toutes les cloches sonnent
son
merveilleusement
cour la François
ni un seul corps une seule
âme le prêtre pour
toujours soyez une pure flamme qui
s'élève et qui proclame la grandeur de
notre
[Musique]
amour village au fond de la vallée des
jours des nuits le temps a fui voici
quand la nuit
étoilé un cœur sendor François est mort
car toute chè est comme l'herbe elle est
comme la fleur des champ épruit mur
bouquet et GERB
et
déchantoche
sonne
elle chante dans le
vent obsédante et monotone
[Musique]
elle redit au
vivant ne tremblez pas cœur
fidèle Dieu vous fera signne un
jour trouerez s
son
l'éternité de
[Musique]
l'amour